hi my name is gustav my co-worker
stephanie loves slots every day she
talks about sloths there's three
different species of sloths
just love sloths they're just like the
greatest animal and i'm
getting emotional so me being the nice
guy that i am i reached out to the
wildlife learning center and asked if
they had a sloth that we could borrow
for a couple of hours so that we can
surprise stephanie with her favorite
animal
[Music]
so guess what what another video too
sloths of course
slobs
are you serious
no we talk about this all the time i'm
going to one day
[Music]
how'd you get him here
a lot of convincing a lot of phone calls
this is the greatest day of my life
oh my god
oh my god someone someone call my
girlfriend
oh my god gustav you're my best friend
in the world if you ever need a kidney i
have two
oh
my god
[Music]
i don't want to give final thoughts
because that means it's over and i don't
want it to be over this is the greatest
experience of my
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm so life
i'm so happy